it looks like a young man  is in the frame you know you're kind of  like a scrawny young man but still a  young man  and uh he says  hi i've gone by the name matthew matt  for the past three years he's shaving in  the window right but a few weeks ago i  found god again  okay  he hit me out of left field and  completely rocked my world peep the cool  hair my bff did for me it's like a cross  on the back god reminded me of his love  for me  the love i had lost sight of through the  years now he's putting makeup on i  started to see things in a new light  things i hadn't thought about  now you realize wait a second he might  not be a he  a little makeup on the eyes then he knit  me together in my mother's womb exactly  the way he wanted me to be referring to  god and because of this realization i'm  de-transitioning and re-transitioning  into the woman  that god intended for me to be  this is a feel-good video  this is  you actually get a little choked up  about it